good evening my name is rob epstein and
i am honored thank you
it is truly my honor to be one of three
governors representing the fantastic
documentary branch here at the academy
so welcome
along with fellow governors michael
apted and michael moore welcome to our
annual evening
celebrating the nominees and the
documentary categories
what
please
terrific year it's been for nonfiction
film right
truly
truly every one of this year's nominated
documentaries is artful
important and oscar-worthy so
congratulations to all the nominees
last year when i introduced the
moderator for this program
much to michael's dismay i said he was a
man who needed no introduction and then
i proceeded to give him an introduction
but this year i'm going to stick to my
word
so without any further ado please
welcome for the second year in a row a
mighty force in the documentary field
and community
academy award-winning filmmaker author
and governor michael moore
thank you very much
i said just mention that i'm an eagle
scout that's uh
no one never no one ever says that in an
introduction of of mine
i won the pinewood derby one time
thank you
and of course i won the nra marksman
award
as a 12 year old
which brings me back to 10 years ago at
the oscars the oscars 10 years ago
where
we were
fortunate enough to win for bowling for
columbine
and
the
thank you
and
and i had a few words to say
that night uh
and i learned how the microphone goes
down automatically into the uh
into the stage and uh
uh the band
starts playing very quickly
and um
but it was the fourth night of the war
and uh you know it was a confusing time
for a lot of people
here we are 10 years later
um
and especially with the issue of guns
and violence in our society it uh
sometimes it feels when you make a
documentary film and i know many of the
filmmakers here tonight have the same
feeling as
we start out with the best of intentions
those being that
this film will matter
this film will do something
to make
anything a little bit better
and it's sort of what keeps the keeps us
going because
um unlike a fiction film which can be
shot in eight weeks
edited in another eight weeks
our films take a year two three four
sometimes longer years to make
and then in the edit room
that's just the shooting and then we go
to the edit room
and that's where the film really begins
because we don't know what we're going
to get when we go out there to shoot so
you can't really write the film until
you're in the edit room it's it's a
crazy it's a crazy process you shoot the
film first then you write it
and so it's a very it's a very difficult
thing and of course we're all very
grateful to our editors because they are
essentially our co-writers because they
are in the edit room with us
writing and putting that movie together
so a hand for the editors who are here
tonight
so we make these movies in the hopes
that
the world or just maybe even a small
piece of it will be a better place
we make them
in part so that you for a couple of
hours
will have
a fascinating experience
in a movie theater
where you walk out of there at the end
of it exhilarated
upset
thrilled
full of questions
all the things that great documentaries
do
that you can't get it out of your head
an hour later a day later a week later
and
and that's we go for that too because
you know we've chosen cinema
as our
avenue
we could have done other things we could
have run for office we could have joined
an organization we could have
milked cows
we could have done any of a number of
things but we chose the movies
because we liked the movies we like the
idea of going and sitting in the dark
with a group of strangers
and and forgetting everything else
that's going on and and letting that
what's up there on that screen
take us to a place that we haven't gone
before
and these days i just want to paraphrase
what michael apted said last night we
had a a dinner um honoring the
documentary nominees both the feature
docs and the short docs
and uh
michael apted said to the documentary
filmmakers there
that we live in a time
where
uh television
news
is
for [ __ ]
um
he's
michael's a very a british gentleman he
actually didn't use that word but uh
i'm just translating um
we live in a time where newspapers are
dying
or dead
gone
um
and he said to the documentary
filmmakers president it's really going
to be up to you and the others who are
going to come along
to tell the stories that the media no
longer tells
doesn't invest the time to tell it won't
put the money into it into telling it
and is beholden to the five large
corporations that
control the vast majority of our media
of our information in a free society
that's never really
a very good idea
to have the concentration of power into
so few hands
and so i want to echo that to those of
you who are the nominees here tonight
make more of these movies this group of
films this year are absolutely
incredible um you'll see you're going to
see a clips from all of them here
tonight
the shorts are are
powerful and emotional
the features
are um
are some of the most provocative
documentaries i've seen since i've been
a documentary filmmaker this has been a
very powerful year for movies i'm very
proud of the fact that our branch
decided to change the voting process so
that instead of having panels or
committees decide the nominees everyone
in the in the branch voted on these five
nominees
so these
these five nominees represent the true
feeling of the 170 or so members in the
documentary branch but it didn't just
stop there because the other change the
board of governors made this year much
to our
uh happiness
um is that for the very first time
the entire academy this year all 6 000
members are voting on the documentary
category it's on the ballot with all the
other categories equally with everybody
else
and
and the academy decided because this was
the first time we're doing this to spend
the money to send a dvd of each of the
five uh feature films to all six
thousand members that's thirty thousand
dvds that the academy
had made and mailed to the 6 000 members
all all at their expense at the
academy's expense
and so
a lot more people got to watch
documentaries during this oscar season
and and whoever wins on sunday night uh
will be a a fair representation of how
the 6 000 members your peers
feel about the films that you made i can
say this uh reporters out there were
asking who do you think is going to win
and i said i think everybody is going to
win
and i mean that in a somewhat less
facetious way because i
i honestly believe because these films
are so good this year if i could look in
to see how the voting
was going i'm sure that it's very close
it's very close
there isn't like a runaway
they're all runaways this year and um
and you'll see if you haven't seen them
yet you'll see clips here tonight please
rent them get them on netflix uh
download them i guess i shouldn't say
that but um
if you download them send a little check
to the filmmaker fine you can get their
address online and say i watched your
movie for free i feel bad here's twenty
dollars
um
but um
um we're just we're very excited about
the the democratization of our branch
and of our of our art form non-fiction
art form uh nonfiction cinema and so
thank you to those of you who are
academy members who participated in that
this year please do it again next year
uh we're looking forward to the all the
great films we're going to see in uh in
2013. so i think it's time to get
started here uh tonight we here's how
it's going to work um we're going to
start with the documentary shorts
and uh uh you're going to see a a a clip
package uh for that runs about 20
minutes uh where you're going to see
it's not trailers you're going to see
actual scenes scenes from these uh
incredible movies and then i will bring
the directors and producers the nominees
up on the stage here and and we will
have a discussion about their movies and
about documentaries in general
and uh and about airport security and
and then um
we will they will leave the stage and um
uh
we will show you a a package of of clips
from the feature nominees and then they
will come on the stage and we'll have a
great conversation
uh with the nominated five dominated
films the makers of those films here
uh this year that's how the evening goes
uh we hope you enjoy it we're honored to
be here i'm honored to be here i'm
honored to be in the company of of these
uh
great filmmakers and and uh uh i i said
to my wife that after watching the the
all the nominees and the ones on the
short list this year uh don't you feel
just a little less alone
like this is really that we're all that
there's so many more people with this
technology and and these ideas and and
you'll see an international group of
people up here tonight this is i'm very
optimistic about the future of
non-fiction cinema and i hope you are
too so let's uh let's get started here
with uh
a look at the
five nominated films for documentary
short and i'll be back thank you
bye dog
i have too many dreams
i can't tell you all of them
if you couldn't dream you
it's like not having a purpose
because when you dream it's like you
want to get that dream accomplished
so if you can't dream
there's nothing to live for
ah hey
i wouldn't
change anything that's happened to me
in the past
because i think in the end it's made me
who i am
i keep having this dream
it feels so real and
it's pretty crazy
i remember
being on the beach and
it was really really hot but
i like the hot
and i'm pregnant and i'm with my husband
i don't have a husband
but in my dream i knew he was my husband
because i could feel that he loved me
i walked to the
ocean
and i realized that my husband tied a
string around my wrist
in case i got scared he would pull me
back
it was really really pretty like clear
blue
like poor water blue
then this really big beautiful wild
comes swimming towards me
it was scary but for some reason i felt
really safe
i don't turn back
its huge body moves right past me
and disappears into the deep blue
and i'm okay
see that's silly
if i didn't have silly dreams
i'd be totally
totally depressed
because although those dreams are silly
they're like they're fun
and
just imagining how it would be like
it's pretty exciting
when i look around it's it's frightening
there are more
singles
living here than there were
five years ago 10 years ago
and it begins to it's not
it's fight it's not that it's
frightening because this is just the way
life goes but you don't know what you
want to do do you want to stay here
do you want to go back to new york to
where your children are
and if you do that it's not the great
the best thing either it's not
they have their own lives you have your
life your grandchildren have their lives
it's not a very good
trade
staying here is just about the only
thing you can do
because you know people here you have a
life here
in new york there's no such life
and you don't have the time to make it a
new life
not the sick people they're sick
oh that's nice it's an outing
i once got sick they wouldn't come near
they thought i was contagious they
i was i don't know what i had but they
wouldn't come near on the phone
so what are you doing i said i'm sick i
can't go on that's it
and there were only one the sickest one
in the whole neighborhood she now she's
i'm not afraid
i'm dying anyway she had hepatitis
i'll do what do you want i'll go get
anything you want she came in and
everything everybody else wouldn't cause
she came in
but not them i'm telling you they're all
that i'm sitting like by the pool
they're chummy mommies
not everyone feels very good
and uh not everybody wants to hear what
the next one has to say in other words i
don't want to know your complaints
i have my own or you know
and nobody means it they really don't
mean it i know i don't mean it
but it's just a form of um
you just don't want to hear something
that is not very good anymore
self-preservation is number one
always no matter what it is at what age
it doesn't matter
self-preservation is number one always
that's the story here
pretty over here isn't it i love you
the golf course
most women say that to see clumps
is more upsetting than not having a hair
at all waking up and having your pillow
be like a little forest it's really
messy and now that i cut it this much i
think i'm ready to actually
buzz it down yeah
just take a deep breath do you want me
to bring synthetic or anybody
just to sit and talk to you while we do
it
or
yeah i don't know yeah sure yeah okay
let me grab something really quick do
you want to sit on my lap
you can sit on our lap we have boosters
too
this is a good thing
oh wow it's gonna be okay
i promise you
you're good you're doing really you
really are you're awesome
you're doing amazing
you have a funny shaped head or anything
yeah actually a big bunch very nice head
no i could put a towel okay good perfect
take a moment
holy hell
okay i can do it right you could do that
yeah if i can do this this is okay
all right can you deal
yep come on over to the side give you
a nice exploring
my poor honey
when i lost it i went i started crying
for me to say goodbye to my hair
it's
definitely
it's making a point that now i have to
face the fact that yes i am a cancer
patient
so for me
it's devastating
it's like your hair is part of your
identity and that's been taken and then
your eyebrows start to thin and then
your eyelashes fall out and you feel
like you're being erased because of
cancer i don't feel like a woman and i
feel like an alien
i got out my clippers and uh
and we went in and and
shaved her head and we were like kind of
like twins at that point
i wonder why guys wear wigs
except most men can't get a decent wig
frank sinatra had a good wig yeah but he
had a lot of money yeah if i put a wig
on sometimes i put her wigs on i said
dude
the beetles are back
my husband
i don't think he's prepared for me to
die
i think he's envisioned it
and gone over it in his
head but i think he's really
it's almost like he's holding his breath
waiting for that shoe to drop
the unfortunate part is that he's been
holding his breath for a long time
he's running out of breath
he's a mr fix-it
always a mr fixit
but this was something he couldn't fix
when i first saw her
i think was like ninth grade
i always liked the way she walked always
liked her legs
she had a certain way that she walked
all the time and i always loved that
got married after we graduated high
school
the stress is history
i sit here and watch
watch how she's changed i mean the
cancer's changed her
it's just eating her up
she never did anything to hurt anybody
um
um
you know i was fighting with angelique
in the airplane
when they gave her the food she said no
there is salt i said i'm your doctor i
allow you to eat she said no
my god
they are doing red that's good
17 years old girl migraine regulation is
very his massive it's very severe
i'm very
dubious about the visibility of
repairing his dog
food
foreign
so
ciao
really huge
can you see me
so
so
hmm
and that looks like about it for that
i'm a 60 year old vietnam veteran
i've been collecting cans 18 years
and this
is a full-time job
because if you don't do it full-time
you ain't gonna get what you need
i just left a bunch of bottles
cans
on the corner right over there by that
stoplight
but uh by the stop line yeah right okay
all right all right thank you
so we have 5
10
15 20
25 30
45 50.
55 cents
all right
god bless him
see you've been working guy huh
there are people out here totally
dependent on what they make canon
they are out here day and night
canning to survive
there was time when you can get any kind
of odd job over here
you didn't think about canning or
anything like that
hey babe
they're always new
faces you know
they come i don't know where they come
from but they sure do come
my name's walter charles all right man
charles we just got about five bucks
right there
you gotta do what you can survive
yeah there's so many people out here
doing it there i know i know i'm
prepared to a year ago you got that
triple people out here before you
started doing this man what were you
going to be actually i was cooking a
restaurant
me too man
i always showed over the cookbook
yeah hey man nice meeting you man all
right
all right see you in the neighborhood
okay all right man
yeah everybody used to have a job
now getting a job man is like hitting
the lotto
50 cans
250.
walnuts and aromatic herbs
coated in dark chocolate
that's 450 cans
100 million cans
for this townhouse
well
i went to the
screening in new york last week where we
voted
the new york branch or the new york
crowd voted
on these and so we're all in the academy
theater there and
it starts i think with the um
filming the homeless teenager
and then goes uh to the old people who
were dying
and then to the breast cancer
and then when the kids came on who
needed open heart surgery i heard
someone in the back go no
no
oh the humanity
it's like this the world is just such a
horrible place
that is the purpose of the documentary
short subject to remind you
um no but these are these are really you
get a chance to see these uh can you get
them on itunes now are they available or
will be available or you know
is that how can people yeah how can
people see these an innocent day just
just was available on itunes a couple
days ago so you can download right there
and the rest of you just go to youtube
or king's point will be on hbo march 11.
hbo march 11th hbo later this year hbo
later this year download it and send us
twenty dollars
you must be the producer of that film
right yeah exactly
keef hp on the fall and we'll take the
money too
hp in the fall and hbo later this year
and hpla wow
this is like the hbo oscars
except you guys so yeah that begs the
question then
how come hbo didn't fund this film
what was wrong with you our next film is
on hbo
um how did you how did you then put this
together without the help of the great
and wonderful sheila nevins
the late show tonight we'll have sheila
will
it'll be real sex 32 or whatever
that's a documentary uh yeah
you know our film was privately put
together you know like we have
amazing producers working on this and
you know well they're here alvi hecht
and yael and ryan brooks and and you
know there's others but it's just it was
a
group activity it takes a village i mean
there are people out there that want to
see
films about social issues so they
they put money up to do that and we're
lucky enough to know some of those
people and they believe in in these
things uh albie hecht from shine global
who produced our film he
um with yael and and and ryan but alby's
group shine global is to end the
exploitation of children through film
that's right that's pretty amazing well
it's a very powerful movie the film
their film is uh uh innocente right is
that correct
and uh it's about a homeless teenage
girl here in los angeles and uh it's a
very powerful movie but yet a hopeful
one too um because she's an incredible
talent
and really makes you wonder how how much
other art how much other talent we're
missing from people that otherwise don't
have an avenue certainly don't have a
means
because of the growing and divide
economic divide in our society and just
which makes me want to ask you this
because i think about this all the time
with films especially documentary films
especially shorts
um
you know we can show all these problems
that exist there's homelessness
cancer
the street people in new york
um
at any point during the making of the
film do you say to yourself you know
as journalists because this is what
documentary is um we're doing the basic
you know the who what
when where how but not often so much the
why
why
are there so many people
walking around los angeles with a
shopping cart
why
haven't we licked cancer
better by now um
how can the upper west side of new york
um
uh tolerate
uh people having to survive uh like that
and i'll i'll just throw this question
out to any of you anybody who wants to
to take it because uh
because i know that's the that's that's
that's a that's the harder thing to deal
with you can you can show the
homelessness you can tell how it
happened
you can tell where it is
but why is it
and what is our responsibility as
documentary filmmakers to ask that
question or to answer or help to answer
that question why well 30 years ago when
my mother was diagnosed with breast
cancer this was before pink ribbons this
was before we even said breast i mean
that was a bad word we called it lung
cancer
and so working on mondays at racine
it was actually
inspiring because you saw change happen
and you saw things get better it wasn't
the death sentence that it was 30 years
ago when i saw my mother go to a wig
store with a lot of shame
um
and cambria did your mother survive no
she she died 30 years ago um january
and so it was incredibly inspiring
because
things get better
and i think that that was one of the
reasons we wanted to tell this story and
help people feel less alone
a friend of mine always says that
structural problems demand structural
solutions and i think that we all all of
these films show really deep structural
problems and and the why why is this you
know
ultimately our film is about like a
little girl and you know
eight little kids who need surgery and
if you look at the globe the larger
issue of global inequity and social
justice and healthcare which i know you
know quite a bit about um you know
there's there are deep structural
problems that do require structural
solutions and and then why is it
tolerated i mean why is it okay
for you know if a kid had that problem
here in the u.s you know would they get
surgery when would they get surgery if
it's a death sentence in africa and i
think that
um
hopefully what we're doing is
bringing up the issue
showing that it's an individual problem
and it's a structural problem
we talk about it i mean it goes larger
in our film
and then in addition we have impact
campaigns i think everyone here now has
impact campaigns associated with their
film that really do add up to real
change beyond just a single kid getting
surgery we've just found out today that
the government of rwanda is committing
major real action
to helping in dramatic heart disease in
africa it's something as simple as you
know strep throat and screenings and
making sure that that it's treated so
yeah the y for us actually came in a
a phone call today which was really the
reason we made the film the phone call
was from the
rwandan minister of health saying we saw
the film
and we are now going to allocate
resources
to solve this problem in rwanda and
they've committed to build a wing in a
hospital and bring cuavo a small remote
hospital where they're going to
construct a center of excellence in
cardiac care which is a first for the
country so for us this was the greatest
achievement
what's gonna
what's gonna happen to the dictator of
sudan you have him uh momentarily in the
film
and uh what's he gonna think when he
sees uh this movie what are you what are
you worried about that at all or um he's
coming to keith's house tomorrow
actually the screen yeah
well if it's true no
i do have an interesting story to tell
um for those who haven't seen the film
which is probably uh but it has to stay
in this room yeah i cannot leave this
room please
you're very good about that here yeah
um
i did not seek
president bashir to be in my film um but
when we arrived in rwanda
we were invited by the sudanese
ambassador to one over for dinner and he
did not tell us that there were going to
be any other guests it was just supposed
to be a casual thing
a
half hour into the dinner in walks five
guys and one was the head of the secret
service of sudan one is the head of the
armed forces it was pretty much every
badass
from sudan in rwanda
and at a certain point um i i made a
comment to the ambassador he had two
young boys that were serving us tea
we all were dying for a drink but you
know
they wouldn't give us drinks obviously
and i say to him wow your boys are so
well behaved and he's like oh well i
know you know you have a wife kathleen
and your son liam yeah
my son's five years old and
i couldn't think of a time when i'd put
that online anywhere so i said well how
do you know this information he's like
well we have our ways and it was
and uh do you know where liam is right
now
at this moment
do you see him in the audience
he's with the babysitter and cartoon
somewhere the babysitter exactly
i also want to say though sometimes
you know as documentary filmmakers we're
always asked that question what about
the why but oftentimes we're not about
asked about storytelling or filmmaking
and i sometimes think that that gets
left aside i think we're all
storytellers we're all great filmmakers
you saw great examples of cinematography
editing sound design all these things
that make our films i think just as
great as the feature films that that are
at the oscars and sometimes i think the
why comes from all of you
like i like that our films tell stories
and then you guys like what you said
tonight they go home
think about it a day later a couple days
later a week later it sits in your crawl
and you can't stop thinking about what's
happening to this homeless girl are
there other homeless kids out there why
is this happening and that's you want us
to go home and i want it to catalyst it
bothers us right
and if you if you travel anywhere else
uh in the developed world
uh you don't see that scene that you see
here in los angeles in toronto or
stockholm or
or i want you to also say you know why
is that though why are we why are we
cutting art
i just watched a girl who who used art
to better herself why is art being cut
in our in our society i just watch a
homeless girl that probably would be
nowhere
you know and and so i want that to stick
with people i want people to start
thinking about it and talk because i
mean there's a there's a feature film
here how to survive a plague that's
about a movement about people thinking
about things and it starts from a small
idea your films do that all these films
do that and i think that sometimes that
gets lost as documentary filmmakers were
expected
for some reason to be the big voice and
the answer and everything but it's not
enough to tell someone's story that no
one else would ever hear and i think
that's really important for at least for
me and for you know and i think what the
two of you do really well they were
nominated for a documentary feature uh
back it was a 2009 what was it eight
for a movie called war dance
and uh
as an incredible film but something that
the two of you do in your films
is you not only are really good
storytellers
the craft
that goes into your films i mean you saw
just a little bit of it there with the
art
it's it's really beautiful i mean it's
obvious you spend a lot of time thinking
about the shot uh thinking about how
this is going to come together and and
and you know you can be a good
storyteller but maybe not be a very good
artist and and it's sometimes you know
you don't have a filmmaker doesn't have
all those tools available you both of
you seem to to have that i'm really
in the interest of full disclosure i
should say that uh when i made my first
film roger me uh
his parents uh were a big help to me
because i didn't know how to make a
movie and
they were uh uh producers on 60 minutes
and they were in dc and i was in dc and
they before the media got bad yeah
they would give me their spike their
splicer
teach me how to do things it was very so
again i thank your parents uh for for
that
um
okay so uh well that's that's really
that's a that's i i just feel like often
times it's it's brought up with us at
film festivals i don't know if you guys
have the same are you an activist are
you like i've been on panels about
activism both of us have right and i
think that there's a there's a
everyone's on a spectrum about why you
make a film and what you hope to have
happen with it and i think that you know
from where we come from
we want to create a world that you
immerse yourself in and we'd use our
craft to do that to really understand
what is it like to be this person and in
all the different ways and and because
she's an artist that opens all these
beautiful doors for us to be able to
play with and we work you know jeff
consegue was here as an amazing editor
and he cut ward ants and he got this and
and we spent an enormous amount of time
to create this emotion and experience
about what it is to be that person
and i think that that sort of transforms
and it brings people on a journey
that you end at the end you get to the
end and it's that thing i don't want to
stop thinking about this person i can't
get them out of my head and we used our
craft i think to be able to do that i
think one way to answer that question
when you're asked you know or do you
consider yourselves activists is i mean
so what i say i just say no i consider
myself a citizen in a democracy that
automatically implies i'm an activist
because if we don't if we're not active
it ceases to be a democracy and that's
just kind of i mean we all have to be
activists in that sense because we're
citizens so
mr alpert
i have watched your films uh since i was
a child
thank you michael i really appreciate it
this man um i don't know how familiar
you are with john albert uh
he uh yes um
man i can go back literally into the 70s
uh with you um
and the first the first that's when
you're walking 20 miles to school in
this in the snowstorm
well i just remember some of the first
reports i saw coming out of el salvador
central america nicaragua
it was you and a camera and somehow nbc
nightly news or whoever was you were
getting the gig from
allowed you to go in and do these
incredible uh reports
and um and it really it personally
inspired me i think inspired a lot of
other people to see how how the what can
the filmmaker do because you really had
to sort of insert yourself in a lot of
these uh situations and uh
um and i'm sure you've i mean you've
you've been in many wars you've you've
done a lot of a lot of these films i
don't know if you know that i mean
you've you've won a peabody you've won
uh a couple dupont awards you've won
emmys
and you're still at it i just uh and he
has this incredible thing in downtown
new york city called the downtown uh uh
tv uh dc tv uh and is that right dc tv
it is okay so let's let's not talk about
let's talk about our center because we
we have a center in new york where we
train 250 high school kids how to do
this work and we've shown
uh the films to them and they're all
inspired by the great work that
everybody here has done
uh we have equipment for independent
filmmakers we're building the first all
documentary all the time theater and i
want everybody to come and show their
films there
uh
this is this is dc tv
and if any you're in chinatown in new
york city please come by and swap
stories with us and let us help you make
your films
you're on broadway and what
uh lafayette and white street right
around
the tombs yeah so like when michael gets
arrested he comes out of jail he comes
over to d.c too
no i don't get arrested because
you wouldn't see me again
um
but uh
you two have been silent here now you uh
spence
you were down there in florida at the uh
old folks uh retirement village and i
believe your grandmother lives there is
that right she lived there she lives
she's passed away now yeah and so i
assume that's where you got the idea to
uh to make this film because
anytime you spend uh three or four hours
around
uh i mean they're all sort of comedians
in one way or another
and it's it's a very touching film and
and funny and sad too i mean it's you
really uh
i have to say after when i got done
watching i did i did not want to get any
older than what i am right now
because
it looks like an awfully lonely uh
existence uh just how did you deal with
that
well i i mean first i just wanted to
respond to what you guys said about
about the craft and about our sort of
role as storytellers and activists and i
think it's really interesting because i
didn't i didn't start to make this film
with the idea that i wanted to say
something about aging i made the film
because i was experiencing something and
i saw it and i wanted to share it with
people and i wanted to other people to
feel what i felt when i was down there
and then it took sort of time
ten years to be exact to finish the film
and uh and it was during that time that
it became obvious that that aging as a
as an issue was very important for our
country to be dealing with in 2030
there'll be more than i think it's over
25 percent of our population will be
over 65
and so it became that later but it
didn't start out that way and and as
these guys said it started out as a as a
desire to
sort of exemplify this this feeling that
i had
um cynthia you made um uh you won the
oscar actually a few years ago no that
wasn't you um who won oh you there you
are sorry
um i confuse white people a lot
um
um
i'll come to you the oscar winner in a
second all right
um
now how do how did you hook up with this
uh this story because you didn't have
anybody down there in the in the
retirement village no i didn't i didn't
have any relatives uh in that particular
um retirement community i i had i had uh
i i work with my brother todd um on on
the production side and we had seen uh
many of the films that sarah had edited
and we had wanted to work with her for a
long time the story that sarri wanted to
tell was very personal to us
i had two grandparents that actually had
a different experience
they had spent their entire lives until
their early and mid 90s living in the
same house
for close to 70 years
and
we discussed the issue with them whether
they as they had aged my grandfather
worked as a lawyer in new york city
until he was 92
whether they wanted to
move to a retirement community whether
they wanted assisted living
they were very independent fiercely
independent and they didn't
and their experience was very very
different on the other hand my my my
father's mother my grandmother uh my
paternal grandmother uh
did need help and she did want to live
in a in in a community and she did for a
period of time
until she reached
towards the the latter the latter parts
of her life and she came home to live
with my uncle and she passed away living
living with him
so i had seen both sides of the spectrum
and from our perspective we felt that
this issue in particular
the issue of the elderly
is an issue that's largely marginalized
in our country it's not really addressed
the emotions that the elderly go through
in our country in the latter part of
their lives their needs their wants
their desires for love their desires for
friendship for companionship
and those stories are rarely told
um and as sarri said as our country
begins to age you know the national
institute for aging
has said in the next 15 years 25 percent
of our country is going to be 65 years
or older i mean and they've they've said
there is a silver tsunami
coming and our country is largely
unprepared
um so these issues were very personal
for us because i dealt with these issues
with with regard to my with regard to my
with with really both sets of my
grandparents i just i kept thinking of
that john prine song hello in there uh
anybody remember that song well this is
very it's just a very very and and i sat
there thinking
this problem that you're showing in this
movie um
that can't necessarily be corrected with
public policy or legislation i mean this
is a very
interpersonal human
thing as to how we treat our parents and
grandparents and what
uh to do
and it's um
uh it's it's yeah i think it's i think
it really made me think a lot and i
think the people who saw it feel the
same way
now um
um free help was your documentary so
five yes five years ago five years ago
yes yeah that's why
um
this was did anybody see this
documentary five years ago free held it
um
documentary short she won the oscar for
it and uh it was a story about
um a police officer in a new jersey town
who was a lesbian
and um the uh city
would not
allow uh her a partner right to
be on the health insurance to receive
the same benefits and she had i think
cancer right yes she was dying of cancer
um she was a policewoman um in new
jersey and been on the force for 25
years had been on the front lines doing
a lot of drug busts working with these
macho big cop men
and had been quietly a lesbian all of
that time and had a long-term partner
female domestic partner life partner and
wanted to leave her earned pension to
her female life partner and was denied
based on the gender
of her her partner and it became this
huge fight in new jersey i ended up
living with her in the last 10 weeks of
her life
her partner was going to lose their
house was it an auto mechanic and was
going to lose their house without the
pension and all of these macho burly
cops who wouldn't have considered
themselves lgbt activists gay activists
suddenly became activists because it
became personal and so um that was an
unexpected story that i ended up sort of
i just thought i need to be there and
ended up living with them and yeah are
you surprised that five years later um
how much farther the ball has moved down
the field on this issue i mean because
back then it seemed pretty hopeless
you know yes
uh
and i think i i just i know your film
got around a lot was played played a lot
of played on tv
and i got to believe that some people
saw that and just thought well this is
just wrong yes you know i have to really
kind of check my bigotry here because
this just is
i'm a human being this is just wrong it
was very i think um i really wanted to
thank you again for making that matt um
matt you worked with john on the the can
uh the the people pick up the cans
and um
now again another thing you don't we
don't see in documentaries very much is
humor
um and so there you had this uh this
humor in your film sometimes
fairly dark humor
nonetheless uh you know anybody who's
been to new york or lives in new york
knows how this whole thing works and
again as i said with the finds here that
uh
i don't know of any other major city you
can go to in the western or the
developed world where you see that when
you see people having to collect cans in
order to survive i can't think of where
my travels of where
uh that exists so we see it all around
the world is the truth you know if you
go to indonesia or iraq you see the
third rape films about you know in egypt
about the the gleaners there yeah but to
see it in our own city right i mean we'd
come home from shooting
alternately
outraged at the level of poverty uh
right here in the richest city in the
world or right in our city
but inspired by the people who are in
the film so you ask about humor you know
that's that's not our humor that's their
humor they're out there in the freezing
cold canning 20 hours a day and they
they do it with a light heart and and
they work
so hard and i think that's something
that people don't understand about
poverty in america right now is that we
have a real poverty problem we have
people going to bed hungry we have
people who want jobs that can't find
them and there's you know there's a lot
of ink spilled on the 47 percent the
takers and so on and so forth these guys
aren't takers they're taking nothing
except our discarded bottles and cans
and uh they they push me to work hard
and i think when you ask that question
about what a film is in terms of what
you ask of an audience
we're all tempted or at least i know i
am
to say get angry and like reach out to
the audience and say get angry
but i hope that by just watching the
truth of what we see and the worlds that
we slip into
you know you do get angry and you do
work to change things for the better
yeah see unfortunately
in our film
i mean we look at your film good things
have happened good things have happened
good things have happened unfortunately
in our film uh the number of canters
increases exponentially every single day
all the jobs in new york they're gone
85 percent of the manufacturing jobs
disappeared
in our neighborhood in chinatown every
single building used to be filled with
sweatshops and in those days we would
make movies about the terrible
sweatshops
and and we we dream of the days when we
can hear that sewing machine humming all
night long
it's worse
and i believe i remember
just reading in the paper after a
hurricane after sandy
that one of those canning centers was
flooded or was destroyed or
is that is that true or tell us about
that one of the cantors the chinatown
redemption center you didn't see it but
it's really it's this underground place
that you are immersed with dozens and
dozens of people redeeming cans and it
was absolutely wiped out by sandy and
there's been nothing done one of the
canners not in our film but one of the
cameras who was part of that community
drowned and died and mr john who is
someone who is dear to our hearts in a
way you have to see the whole film to
understand him but um but you know we
kept on following up with him and he
didn't have the wherewithal to go
anyplace else to redeem his bottles and
cans and he'd be out there and we'd
bring him soup or we'd bring him tea
and week after week he just was sort of
hanging out there was no social safety
net there was no one there to take care
of him and three weeks ago
he disappeared and we were asking lily
another woman in our in our film what
happened and nobody knows what happened
to mr john uh and we fear the worst in
fact you know and walter who you do see
in the film was killed um by a by an
amtrak train uh near near the tunnel
that he lived in underground you know
there are so many people just clinging
on by their fingertips just that you've
made the film yeah wow wow
uh we just have a few minutes left here
um i'm just curious where all of you are
based are you are you still in dc uh
washington d.c washington dc uh yeah not
what's not the other dc yeah
from there you got to say washington dc
you have to say washington washington oh
okay right it's like don't say frisco
right okay i'm from san francisco you
are from
that was your queue to say frisco yeah
uh i'm i'm i'm based in new york city
i'm actually based uh in the same block
actually where walter uh used to can
yes in fact uh in just seeing this clip
and i've i've seen the film but it just
occurred to me actually in seeing the
short clip i could actually see my
apartment
and i i'd actually remember walter i
remember walter
i now i'm a new yorker but i now live in
western massachusetts in the berkshires
the people's republic of brooklyn
i grew up in new york but i live about
three four blocks away
could walk here
but i won't
ever
the shoes
you feel like a dork if you're walking
in this town it's it's it is it's
weird yeah people look at you as they
drive by like oh
it is kind of weird but you live in new
york now no i live here now you still
live here oh i'm from new york i live
here from new york and you came i got it
okay and i
just moved from liberia west africa to
uh to austin texas and and in san diego
so i split my time between austin and
san diego
and you guys are new yorkers so four of
the five films are essentially based on
the east coast and and one uh
here on the west coast so
so those of you who flew from new york
any uh any problems with immigration
when you
got into lax here
no
no secret room there's a picture of all
of us in hollywood with a red red line
through it
um well just to close out here i'm just
wondering if there's any questions that
you had of each other you've seen each
other's films uh uh
you seem very complementary of each
other's work we all had dinner last
night and
and i'm just uh just curious if there's
anything you'd like to say or ask your
fellow filmmakers i invite the women
nominees to go during the oscars to the
women's bathroom because that is where
the real documentary is taking place
don't go just before your category comes
up though
check the check the program anybody else
any other bathroom issues
i i want to say one thing to andrea and
sean um during war dance i i was working
with some kids from northern uganda and
i think i've mentioned this to you guys
before but i'll share with everyone um
and keith has done a lot of work in
uganda and
um one of the girls that i was that i
was with and i'm quite close to and she
we lived together for for quite some
time was from northern uganda and when
the trailer for war dance came out
she was living here in the states and
she watched that trailer over and over
and over again and it meant so much to
her to see
her people and her experience reflected
in
in a way that was larger than life and
so i just want to thank you guys for
that for someone that i loved that meant
a lot to them and i know a friend who's
going through
breast cancer right now and and just the
idea that that
these experiences are being reflected
and and somehow
acknowledged and witnessed it i think
to me that's that's why i feel so
grateful to be in in this company and my
brother was homeless and canned for a
long time here on the streets of
hollywood and and it's just
that's
i feel very grateful to be in this
company for that so thank you thank you
all
i think
one thing that um
you had just said something about that
just stuck with me about you said you
know these guys you didn't think they
would care but it became personal and
that's what i realized like when i was
watching all these things that
it becomes personal and that's what
all these films i think and great
documentaries you do is that it puts you
on the inside of something and so i feel
like that when i watch all these things
is just how powerful that can be and
that's what our role is i think is these
yeah we're in a day and age where things
are so fast i mean we have two kids and
i'm scared for them i mean things are
just
moving at light speed and our films slow
everyone down i mean i'm gonna like say
hi to guys that collect hands now
because like they're real people they're
not crazy people collecting cans which
i'm sure a lot of people think you know
it's
these things these films all the films
all documentaries give a chance for
people to tell their story and for for
all the normal people out there to stop
and say
hey you know these people are normal too
they just have a different story and i
might talk to them or i might know one
of them or i could be one of them one
day so i should stop take the time and
listen and i think that's really i mean
i just applaud all of us because i think
we're letting people do that take take
the time and listen because we don't
listen anymore in our society we just
absorb and absorb and absorb we don't
stop and and just listen and take time
and i think it's very very important and
this is one of the few crafts that allow
us to do that i think
and i i
i think also michael that um
what uh what michael said last night at
the dinner and which you repeated
earlier uh in the introduction is is 100
correct
there has been a major shift in in media
in this country and
uh there's there is a focus on
filmmaking and there's a responsibility
as documentarians that that that
certainly comes with that and it's a
privilege it's a privilege to be a
documentarian in in here in the united
states and and certainly outside the
united states
and there's a responsibility to tell to
tell these stories um and there's an
opportunity i mean film is is clearly
the most powerful medium i think today
uh to influence people and and to affect
change and
it's an honor i think for all of us uh
to have that opportunity to at least
attempt to affect change and and and
change our society uh food for clearly
the better
well i think that's go ahead you were
gonna say i was just gonna say just how
wonderful it is to
all of us to be up here and our films
are all going to be seen in their shorts
and you know they've been seen already
been seen and continued to be seen and
they're traveling and the shorts were
you know you actually the you this is
the shortest group of short filmmakers
i've seen
in the last five years no seriously i
don't decide a dinner lesson heavier
yeah
well as an editor i think i'm sorry i'm
sorry no but i i think that we also want
to thank you because when you ask why we
make the films we're making the films
because we want to reach people like you
and when you turn out to watch our films
we're really most grateful
um you know so we feel a little bit like
foreigners coming here to hollywood and
to get this type of reception the
reception we've got from the academy
really quite grateful so thank you
well this wraps up our our shorts uh
section tonight and i want to wish all
of you the best of luck on sunday go
there have a good time uh it's a great
experience something that you won't
experience anyplace else
uh and it's uh
and your fellow academy members or the
people who are academy members here take
this
uh
category very seriously and uh and we
know that it's it's also we've seen a
lot of great documentary filmmakers come
out of the shorts category and so we're
big supporters of it next year we're
planning to do actually a musical number
in honor of documentary shorts
on the show so stay tuned for that let's
give one more round of applause these
wonderful filmmakers here nominated this
year thank you